continuer à en parler avec notre invité
sébastien abis bonjour à vous vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'iris est-ce qu'il
ya d'autres pays comme le yémen on vient
de voir ce reportage est ce qu'à
d'autres pays comme le yémen qui
risquent de s'enfoncer encore un peu
plus dans la famine par exemple ont
raison de cette guerre en ukraine il ya
deux catégories de pays il ya des pays
qui comme le yémen connaissent
malheureusement des conflits ddr des
combats depuis des années beaucoup de
pauvreté est évidemment les incidences
de cette guerre en ukraine grands pays
producteurs exportateurs de céréales
renforce en fait les insécurité
alimentaire dans ces pays en détresse
multiples ensuite il ya des pays qui
vont être fortement importateur qui sont
pas forcément en guerre mais qui
dépendent des marchés internationaux
pour construire une partie leur sécurité
alimentaire et quand ce prix de la
nourriture flandre sur les marchés
mondiaux et que sur le théâtre local
vous avez déjà un certain nombre d'
instabilité de l'inflation qui depuis
plusieurs mois progresser ben vous avez
des impacts et donc c'est vrai que cette
guerre en ukraine a là un effet cascade
sur la sécurité alimentaire du monde
parce que encore une fois c'est un grand
pays producteur et exportateur et depuis
le début du conflit il ya six semaines
n'y a plus aucun volume agricole qui est
chargé a exporté depuis l'ukraine
sébastien un bisou nous avait clairement
a expliqué il ya les pays en guerre et
puis ceux qui ne le sont pas et qui ont
tout de même des conséquences dans leur
propre au pays on peut parler de la
france par exemple on le sait maintenant
lui il manque dans certains supermarchés
de l'hexagone
combien de temps il faut à peu près pour
qu'un pays puisse se réorganiser suite à
une guerre qui créent comme ça des
manques on va avoir deux choses on va
avoir d'abord l'effet de laquelle en
ukraine sur certains pays importateurs
sur l'inflation du prix du pain par
exemple va se faire ressentir beaucoup
plus fortement à partir du mois de mai
en mai juin on considère qu'il ya
toujours entre six et huit semaines pour
avoir un impact sur les marchés locaux
on voit au niveau français que si on n'a
pas de problème sur le blé en revanche
on aura de l'impact par exemple sur les
huiles puisque l'huile de tournesol
vient principalement du cren aujourd'hui
est un peu également de russie et donc
on aura un prix de l'huile de tournesol
qui risque de doubler dans les
prochaines semaines dans le rayon des
consommateurs en france et ce sera un
coût qui sera inévitable parce que par
ailleurs les coûts de production
commente les intrants l'énergie et donc
les huiles de substitution par ailleurs
ont un prix qui connaîtra également une
forte hausse quelles pourraient être les
incidences de ce conflit à l'échelle
mondiale en termes d'alimentation est il
peut y avoir des conséquences durables
sur des mois des années oui parce que on
sait que la récolte en ukraine la
prochaine sera fortement dégradée plus
le conflit dure plus l'impact sur la
sécurité alimentaire mondiale et bien
sûr et avant tout d'abord pour les
ukrainiens sera difficile et donc on
voit bien que les marchés mondiaux qui
connaissent une récolte sur les grandes
cultures par an on va avoir un effet sur
un an 2 ans et je rappelle que cette
guerre en ukraine s'inscrit dans un
contexte qui depuis deux ans était
extrêmement tendue l'inflation
alimentaire a démarré avec la crise du
coc vide la crise du covan n'est pas
derrière nous et c'est l'ensemble des
marchés mondiaux qui anticipe aussi des
années difficiles avec toujours une
équation offre et demande extrêmement
inégalitaire on manque pas de nourriture
en europe et en france il ya une partie
de la planète qui malheureusement est
dans l'insécurité alimentaire de manière
structurelle et quand un conflit dans le
monde surgi dans un grand pays
exportateur
évidemment c'est de ce coût
supplémentaire à sébastien abis
chercheur associé à l'iris merci à vous
de nous avoir apporté toutes ses
explications pour comprendre les
conséquences de cette guerre en ukraine
sur
la manière de pouvoir alimenter continue
à alimenter le reste de la population
mondiale merci à vous on va parler